do you see this relatively tiny opening
it leads under the women's bathing
rooms okay come on MAR beneath pompei's
oldest bath house cavers are venturing
deep into a miraculously preserved space
that remained hidden for nearly 2,000
years I'm actually not sure how long
they stay there we'll see how long they
survive
okay oh look down there there's
a there's a
bat they're searching for Clues to life
and death in the Roman
Empire what do you think is written in
the
a I think is a
stump
Pompei an ancient city 130 Mi south of
Rome in ad79 Mount Vesuvius just 6 M
away erupted
explosively smothering the entire area
beneath millions of tons of volcanic ash
and rock 7
centuries later archaeologists
rediscovered a city Frozen in
time but even after almost 300 years of
excavation a third of pompei's streets
remain
Unearthed today archaeologists from
across the world are digging through the
debris uncovering surprising new
evidence for what it was like to live
and die at the height of the Roman
Empire for an AR sustain pompe is a very
special moment the possibility to touch
the real life 2,000 years ago much of
what we know of the Roman world is
through the lives of those at the top
Emperors senators and Generals living in
their vast Villas and
palaces but the great majority of those
who lived in the Roman World weren't
Rich at
all what was Pompei like lower down the
social order
for the middle classes or enslaved
people we're following a team of
archaeologists Excavating pompe in
search of the real stories of these
hidden
lives every day we discover new things
in Pompei and help to understand the
Roman uh culture in every part of the
world buried up to 20 ft beneath
volcanic debris archaeologists have
Unearthed a bustling
Metropolis homes for some 15,000 people
in a coastal Hub of trade and
culture in the East archaeologists
discover an arena for Gladiator
fights and in the west they unearth two
theaters they uncover temples dedicated
to nine different gods and Emperors and
a forum the heart of business business
and political
Affairs the excavation of perfectly
preserved Pompei reveals Roman Life in
the
roar today an international team of
archaeologists is digging at one of the
most complete Roman bathouses in the
world the stabian
baths good
morning wno K everything fine yeah yes
we German archaeologist Monica truma
first came to Pompei aged 15 on a family
holiday it sparked the fascination of a
lifetime I always wanted to excavate
here this has been the dream site to
excavate I really like digging in the
earth and cleaning things I do not like
cleaning things at home but I like
cleaning things on archaological
sides Monica's team is on a mission to
explore the Hidden World of the Roman
bath house and as always we are running
out of time there's still so much to
do a visit to the baths was part of the
Roman daily
routine bathers would first remove their
clothing then smear their skin with
olive
oil the bathing session began with
exercise to work up a healthy
sweat
Romans didn't use soap instead they
scraped off the oil sweat and dirt with
a tool called a
stdel then bathed in rooms at different
temperatures heated by a hyper a Marvel
of Roman
engineering hot air from a furnace
circulated under the floor and between
the walls to heat rooms up to 100°
f pompe aian baths were in use for
around 200 years before vesuvius's
eruption froze them in the state we see
today the team is digging to solve a
mystery how did a visit to the baths
change over
time we've been studying the stadi in
bath because we're interested in the
development of bathing culture in pompe
their Quest begins behind the
scenes right now what you see is a
service room you see all kinds of
installations that served for the bath
I'm standing on a channel you see
another Channel behind me so these are
all installations belonging somehow to
particularly the water management and
also the heating system it was a room
that the bathers were not supposed to
ever see or enter yeah so it was only
for the slaves Monica and Joint
excavation leader Marco gilio from the
University of Naples Laurent are digging
into dirt that predates the eruption of
ad79 we hope to find all sort of things
not only beautiful object but something
useful for the chronology for dating in
this space dig member Satoshi higuchi
spots a glint of metal in the dirt wow
wow
yeah I can't see it what is it oh yeah
yeah I see it now oh wow what do you
think it might be this could be some
kind of hair pin mhm I guess yes because
it's so thin yes the thin needle
something you would stick into your hair
look at
this there's more of it oh no
it's it's a fibula and this is part of
the fibula then so this is a lower part
of the fibula wow they used to to fix
cloth they use this to fix cloth and
actually if I remember correctly this is
the first one we find here at all in the
stadium
bath the ornate clothes pin is a direct
connection to a poman living 2,000 years
ago it's uh really exciting and really
happy to have found it and um I hope I
can find more interesting things to
understand this bath very interesting uh
find very very interesting now we'll uh
continue to escalate this layer all the
evidence the team has found suggests
this was not always a service room but
was once a public walkway known as a
porticus our hypothesis is that
originally it was a porticus and not a
service room and only later when you
know they they improved or changed the
bath they would have transformed it into
such a service
room when did the layout of the baths
change and
why to find out Monica will need to
explore deep into an Unseen
World just outside pompe City walls
Spanish archaeologist uren alapont is
leading another pioneering
excavation I think for all archaeologist
Bay a
dream it's estimated 2,000 pompeians
perished in the eruption their tragic
deaths have made Pompei world
famous but the Frozen figures reveal
almost nothing of these people's life
stories for greater Insight today uren
is Excavating the tombs of pompe who
died before the
eruption his team has removed tons of
volcanic debris to reach new and
Uncharted tombs where when we start to
work here all this area was completely
covered for this uh pomis stones that
cover completely the city the size of
each freshly Unearthed tomb gives a
first clue to the occupants here we are
in this to on the
podium and of course it's a very rich
person that build this a very big to
inscriptions can reveal further fascin
ating information about the lives of the
Tomb occupants but ur's ultimate goal is
to unearth what lies inside the
tombs our project is try to find this
Remains the human remains because we are
studying the archology of
death it's difficult to discover
forensic detail of the Roman dead due to
the standard funeral rights of the time
when a Roman citizen died relatives put
a coin in the deceased's mouth to pay
for safe passage to the
underworld by law they had to lay the
body to rest outside the city
limits Rich families hired musicians and
professional mourners to lead the
procession at the necropolis they burned
the body on a
p and stored the ashes and the coin in
an N to keep in the family tomb Romans
even cremated their Emperors but they
burned julus Caesar's p in public inside
Rome's City
Limits The mourner's passions Ran So Hot
they almost burnt down the
Forum uren and his team are hunting for
chromation NS but finding human ashes
among tons of volcanic ashes is no easy
task they've just Unearthed this tomb
right next to the main gateway into
Pompei built in an eye-catching
spot if you are reach you choose the
most important gate in the city and of
course you want to will you in front of
this gate so everyone who pays in front
they never forget this
person what we found inside was really
exciting
[Music]
in the southern region of the city is a
residential area known today as insula
17 now guys today we starting in the two
areas to continue the excavation inside
in the layers that we find in the last
days okay now we
go archaeologist Mario Grimaldi is part
of a team from the University of Bologna
that is investig ating the lives of
middleclass people at the height of the
Roman
Empire the volcanic blanket over Pompei
preserved its public spaces its
cemeteries its baths and its Grand
buildings but it also preserved over a
thousand ordinary private
homes these rarely survive elsewhere so
Pompei offers a unique opportunity for
archaeologists in Pompei we have the
possibility to understand the real life
the people uh that live in these houses
with the material the artifacts that
these people had in the her hand before
the
eruption is important for us to
understand the this Society this people
that liveed in this area they like a
middle class people in the
society beneath the street that runs
alongside the houses the team makes a
discovery
we have a water
pipe now we're cleaning this water pipe
is very interesting for
us the water pipe is a connection from
the aqueduct to the water for the fresh
water Roman Plumbing was the Envy of the
ancient world networks of underground
lead pipes channeled water from
aqueducts along city
streets most residents collected their
water from roadside fountains but richer
homeowners could go one step further if
uh uh I want in my private house the
fresh water I pay with my money the
connection to the
aqueduct if you are lucky it's possible
that we find the stamp of the
owner but as the team searches something
extraordinary begins to appear in the
same Trench that could give an even
bigger insight into these inhabitants
lives okay guy what do you find we
actually find a a scout oh
amazing in their quest to investigate
the occupant of this large tomb ur's
team hits the
jackpot in front of this St we found
description who tell as the owner was
Marco benero
suo this stmp this discovery is one of
the most important Discovery in my
career the size and location of Marcus
venerus sako's tomb shows that by his
death he must have been a prominent
figure in
Pompei but what uren Unearthed beside
the plaque was a complete
surprise
the tomb was revealed to be a walled
family
enclosure in one corner uren found a
small
Tombstone beneath it an N containing the
cremated ashes of a
woman then the team spotted a sealed
door leading to a burial chamber
containing Marcus venerus cundo skeleton
still sporting hair and part of his left
ear he was buried not
burnt an unparalleled opportunity to
discover more about an individual life
and death in
Pompei this is the best preserve uh body
ever found in Pompei we were very
surprised when we found this body bed
and no cremated because everyone all
bodies in Pompei are cremated that he's
the only one bored in
Pompei there are even hints Marcus may
have been embed after death scraps of
textile found among the remains may be
wrappings to help preserve his
body as soon as the remains were
photographed the team rushed them into
cold
storage now the body is inside one
fridge at 3° because we want to preserve
all this organic material now we can do
analysis genetic analysis of these
remains wear on the teeth alongside
other signs of aging on the skeleton
suggest Marcus lived to at least 60
years
old uren Hope's further analysis will
reveal more about his Origins where he
grew up and perhaps how he
died but starting from the plaque on
Marcus's tomb uren wants to piece
together key parts of his life
story Marco benus Colonia
lius so the scriptions say he was first
the slave of the city but after he
becomes a free man lius so he got the
freedom the inscription and the tomb
location reveal that by the time of his
death mark us was a prominent citizen in
Pompei next yuren wants to find out how
Marcus gained his freedom and his wealth
and what his rise says about life in the
Roman
[Music]
Empire at the stabian baths monik is
following in the footsteps of baers
2,000 years
ago this is the final room of the
women's Suite it's the caldarium the hot
room and the baths weren't just
somewhere for citizens to get
clean we have ancient L resources that
you know complain about the noises
coming from Bath it's not like one of
our you know luxury spas where you have
quiet you know music and so on and must
have been really really really noisy
really
loud archaeological evidence indicates
that the stabian baths serve served
multiple
purposes more than simply being a place
to get clean they were a vital Social
Hub the main place where Romans caught
up with friends or discussed casual
business Monica wants to identify the
technology that was key to this social
function so this is the immersion pool
for the women it was heated From Below
by the floor heating it was heated from
from the back and the sides by the Wall
heating and then it has one additional
really intriguing feature you really
have to kneel down in order to
appreciate this it's a half circular
container made out of bronze and it's
closed at the back and open here in the
front and so the water constantly goes
in there and this thing is right above
the hottest part of the the fireplace so
right next to the fire so to speak and
so therefore it always heats the cooling
water and then the hot water comes out
again and this so this helps
additionally to keep the water
warm the hot water container is called a
testudo it's named for its
shape testudo in Latin means
tortoise they are unfortunately rarely
preserved because the metal is very
precious and was usually red out in
Antiquity or any time later so this
example here is particularly intriguing
because it's fully preserved it is so
rare and is so so
exciting this is clever Roman
technology maintaining the bath water at
a constant pleasurable temperature so up
to half a dozen women could relax and
socialize it's particularly important to
get as much information as possible of
such a well-preserved example from all
sides exploring the testudo in detail
may also give insight into how the bath
served as a highly sociable
space but there is a
problem I can kind of crawl inside from
the pool because the opening is very
very narrow and the channel is narrow to
examine the precious testudo properly
Monica needs a different
approach
just outside Pompei City walls another
team is exploring
underground archaeologist Luana tonolo
has helped excavate 20 ft of volcanic
rock and Ash to reach a small room part
of a much larger
Villa this is our really latest
Discovery as you can see we are still
working of it so for us it's really
exciting and every day there is
something new over there you can see the
window from where the volcanic ash
entered and covered the objects in this
room and actually preserved
it ever since excavations began in
Pompei nearly 300 years ago diggers have
found skeletons inomed in the volcanic
ash the Flesh of the dead has long since
decomposed leaving only a body spaced
shape surrounding the
bones by pouring plaster into the cavity
the archaeologist are able to recreate
the original body shape we are still
using the same technique more than one
century ago because it's really the best
technique this team is using plaster to
capture the original shape of other
organic
objects they wait for the plaster to set
then very carefully scrape away the
surrounding
Ash we don't know what we are going to
see when we put the plaster in the holes
and what we found is in this game is the
bed not just one but three beds complete
with blankets and an array of bedside
furniture and storage
containers you can see three beds made
of wood this bed are really simple you
can see that they are made of vertical
piece of
wood three people shared this small room
the basic furniture and the single small
window suggest that they were among the
poorest of Pompei
it was used as a room where to sleep and
relax but at the same time is a storage
room because there you can see storage
containers that were used in Roman times
to trade food wine
Olive the Other very important object
that we can find in this room is this
particular object that is the part of
the Chariot that was used to link The
Chariot to the
horses and incredibly the plaster cast
here reveals a rope
lashing the evidence has prompted Pompei
archaeologists to call this the room of
the
slaves it is the most complete example
of such a room ever discovered in the
Roman Empire this room is very important
for us for the archaeologist for the
historians because we can see actually
how slaves and poor people
lived there would have been several
hundred rooms like this in and around
Pompei it's exactly the sort of place
where Marcus venerus cundo may have
started his
life but as Marcus's life shows
enslavement wasn't necessarily a life
sentence in the Roman
[Music]
Empire in ancient Rome enslaved people
were a commodity auctioned at a
market those that were unskilled could
be worth the annual salaries of two foot
soldiers some had tags attached to their
necks as proof of ownership in case they
fled those that were educated could be
put to work as accountants or
secretaries they had higher status and
so were paid for their
duties enslaved people could use their
money to buy their freedom acquiring
Roman citizenship in a formal
ceremony as a symbol of their Liberty
they wore a felt cap called a
pilus Marcus's tomb and inscription
reveals he became a wealthy man uren
wants to know how he bought his way out
of
enslavement at the stabian baths
monik is venturing deeper into the
incredible unseen Roman World preserved
at
Pompei this is kind of the the heart of
the bath this is a service section and
the heating system but what exactly this
heating system looked like we do not
know and we really want to explore it's
quite narrow to get into it's quite
dangerous Monica works with a team of
spel ogists specialist cavers to venture
where she can't
B Monica hopes the cavers can find
evidence of how and when the baths were
modified we do not know whether the
whole heating system was remodeled or
belongs to an older period so I'm I'm
really exciting and looking forward to
to
pictures Maro traces the route the
scorching hot air would have taken into
the heating system 2,000 years ago he's
one a few to venture into this dangerous
void since Pompei was buried in volcanic
[Music]
rock I'm actually not sure how long they
stay there we'll see how long they
survive ur's investigation into the life
of Marcus venerus cundo has brought him
to the western edge of
Pompei Marcus's tomb inscription states
he worked as a custodian looking after
the Temple of
Venus this is what I'm looking for this
is the original flaw of the Temple of
V Romans worshiped many gods and had
many temples in their honor but Venus
was the chief deity and protector of
Pompei natural disasters have sadly
reduced pompei's largest sacred sight to
Rubble uren hunts for any remains of the
Temple's inner sanctum that would have
contained the statue of Venus here in
the temple we we preserve the gate
system here was was
Marcus who was opening this uh massive
doors in the temple of Venice only the
stones beneath the doorway remain but
uren suspects Marcus would have guarded
this inner sanctum the temple was not
always open so when the temple was
closed people come here and leave the
office and probably Marco venarius came
to collect them to bring them to to the
to the
temple working in pompei's most hallowed
Temple would allow Marcus to mingle
among pompei's Elite he was likely to
have been rewarded for his work perhaps
through tips or donations of course the
custodia of this uh Temple was very
popular and and he has a very good
reputation in
bompe the wealth and high status that
Marcus gained at the temple may have
allowed him to buy his
freedom once he'd escaped enslavement
Marcus's life took on a truly dramatic
twist pompei's latest discoveries are
opening up a new window into everyday
life in the Roman
Empire Pompei is much more than a city
divided into wealthy Elites and their
downtrodden
servants this was a society where you
could rise out of enslavement and
citizens of all classes relaxed in
communal
baths at insula 17 Mario's team has
found a buried
skull uh we don't know which animal it
is what's intriguing is the skull's
location just beneath the street level
and close to an underground water
pipe for us it's very interesting this
fun of this school because uh we are in
front of a a real time and a real life
in this area before the eruption of 79
the team is trying to find other clues
that could shed light on their Discovery
yeah yeah you find also other bones
around
yes yeah okay a tantalizing possibility
is this is the skull of an animal killed
as a sacrificial offering to the gods
but Mario needs more evidence
the team hunts for Telltale ceramic cups
that would once contain other
offerings other part of theion there
yeah we don't found the the caps
in now we continue to cleaning we remove
the school uh and to understand if there
are old parts of the bones of the school
of the
anal the team must carefully extract all
the compacted soil before they attempt
the delicate task of removing the
skull the cavers are crawling ever
deeper into the underfloor heating
system okay come on
MAR they must document every detail of
the Subterranean
world no one knows what could lurk in
this
space Oh look down there there's
a there's a
bat so the spaces over there are lower
what the spaces over there are lower
yeah it's around 15 cm the invention of
the hyper coost system revolutionized
bathouses allowing bathers to linger
longer in pleasantly warm water before
stepping onto a heated
floor but Comfort above ground creates a
highly hazardous cramp space
below I hear some voices so they must be
working but I can't see them anymore
under the women's hot immersion
pool the cavers find in photograph one
of the best preserved testudo in the
Roman World built to be both fire
resistant and water tyght
the Tank's sloping Underside had been
carefully engineered so that the heat
from the furnace that was once nearby
created a circulating supply of hot
water beneath the floor of the women's
caldarium the cavers spot something else
that could help Monica's
investigation what do you think is rest
in the
air I think is a
stmp
at the insula 17 housing block the Dig's
Chief archaeologist Antonella corini is
overseeing the delicate retrieval of the
animal
skull if they don't release all the
compacted soil around the 2,000-year old
skull it could
shatter
I oh
beautiful this is the
Heat this is not school of ship it's a
school of a bull it's very interesting
now it's a fascinating find the skull of
a
bull very big big the point of H it's
interesting because it's very strange
that we find a school a school of
bull a bull's skull is a rare find in
Pompei in ancient Rome Bulls were highly
prized and expensive
animals January was Liv for the gods for
the ritual
sacrifice Romans believed animal
sacrifices could offer insights into the
will of the Gods Bulls were among the
largest and most prestigious animals
killed in this
way an animal that showed no fear before
its death was a good omen a sign of
approval from the
gods the animal's internal organs were
inspected by a priest called an
orer if they looked diseased or damaged
the sacrifice had to be repeated with a
new
animal if the organs were healthy the
Romans offered a p to the gods by
burning them on the Altar and then
feasted on the rest of the
animal the team carefully cleansed the
skull ready for future expert
investigation marks left by axe or
Hammer blows might confirm Mario's
suspicion the bull was killed in a
sacrificial ritual for us now is
important to understand why this bull uh
was livid in this uh area in front of
this wall it's a possibility for us that
uh we have a this ritual uh time in this
area before the eruption of
79 the team suspects that it's no
coincidence the skull was found here
right alongside the fresh water
pipe perhaps the bull was sacrificed to
commemorate these homes making their
connection to the public water
supply ur's investigation into the life
of Marcus venerus cundo has brought him
to one of pompei's most spectacular
sites wow this is so
beautiful this is the Aion of Pompei
a very important
[Music]
place the odium was one of two theaters
in
Pompei it acoustic is really special
really really particular
so you can hear how the sound is
surrounding you the Aon was just for
music and uh music per performance and
for music uh
Opera they built one particular place
just for this kind of uh
shows the inscription discovered on
Marcus's tomb reveals that after he
gained his freedom he became a priest
and paid for a 4-day festival of games
plays and
music to pay all this performance all
these Musical shows of course he must be
very very rich in that moment for sure
Marco benero was a very important one of
the most important person in
Pompei Marcus's Festival could also
reveal why he was buried and not
burnt the inscription specifies
performances in both Roman Latin and
also Greek this was a complete
surprise is he weak or he was very uh
close to the Greek culture and we know
that Greeks in Greece they have ination
they have burial in that
moment Greek plays and the Greek style
burial suggest either Marcus had Greek
ancestors or he was a great fan of Greek
culture the DNA analysis might resolve
the mystery ur's discoveries allow him
to piece together the drags to Rich's
story of the best preserved body ever
found in
Pompei Marcus venerus cundo was enslaved
by the city of Pompei a subject of not
one but of all the citizens they chose
him to guard a Temple dedicated to Venus
the patron goddess of
Pompei when Marcus was freed from
enslavement he joined the orust stales
an elite order of priests devoted to The
Cult of the
emperor like his fellow priests he
became a rich benefactor and funded a
festival of plays music and
games his wealth and high status
afforded him a Monumental tomb among the
most prominent in
Pompei it's like a dream is something
very uh impressive very very amazing
Marco benius was a slave of the city and
he ends becoming one of the most
important person in
Pompei under the stabian baths cavers
Mao and Mario discover a rare stamped
inscription m
a
m
a f i wonder if there's
more it's crucial to take a clear
photograph to get the best possible
evidence for
[Music]
Monica are you done oh perfect can I see
what you found yes what is that this is
the
stud see wow wow perfect oh yeah you can
kind of see incredible the photos reveal
that from the underside the bronze
plates of the immersion pool hot water
tank are joined with two neat rows of
rivets the overlapping plates look like
an armored animal shell another
compelling reason why the Romans used
testudo the Latin word for toris for the
tank two ruls everywhere the the two
sheets overlap I think this is one of
the best preserved ever and you can also
really see it from below and from above
and and fully study how it worked and
this makes it really
exciting the discovery of the stamp
could help solve the biggest
mystery how did the layout of the baths
change over
time right over here is where we found
the stamp so we have the an an m m
R yeah yeah o or Q mhm maybe an r and m
again M again and this looks like a p
and this could be an F the stamp is a
Mark that identifies the tile maker it's
a totally unexpected find oh wow perfect
this is like the first complete stamp I
know of in the saan bath and wow this is
really
exciting matching the stamp to others in
Pompei could give an exact time period
for the floor's
installation whether this stamp is known
in Pompei because it's really really
important it might potentially give us a
date for the hypoc cost system so this
is really exciting if it's really a late
stamp we would have a proof that they
had to remodel it further analysis
reveals the tile stamp is one of several
in Pompei that appear to date to after
a62 in that year a major earthquake
rocked the city and damaged many
buildings the people of Pompei took the
opportunity to modernize the building
fitting a brand new floor above an
upgraded heating
system but the citizens had only a few
years to enjoy their Majestic new bath
house before vesuvius's cataclysmic
eruption in
ad79 everything we excavate that we
reveal I think adds to the picture of
history of Roman Pompei in a significant
way so excavation really has a purpose
to to help us reconstruct history Pompei
is slowly giving up its Secrets
revealing the everyday lives of its
people bathers enjoying the public baths
worshippers making offerings to their
gods and enslaved people rising to great
wealth as archaeologists continue to
excavate this extraordinary 2,000-year
Old City Frozen in Time their
discoveries will shed fresh insights
into life and death at the height of the
Roman
[Music]
Empire